when I look at a floppy disk today I
look at something that's valuable that I
use and yet when most people look at it
they'll look at it almost as a joke
floppy disk aam I'm the last man
standing in the floppy disk business
because I basically forgot to get out of
the business in this office we're in a
time warp the manufacturing of the
diskettes is over and so all the
diskettes that will be made have been
made I'm desperately trying to acquire
as many diskettes as I possibly can all
kinds of disks come flying into our
doors from time to time
commercial recycler will call me up and
say hey I have somewhere between 35 and
50 thousand disks we sort them we run
them through a process to erase the
information once the diskettes are
reformatted and relabeled we're able to
resell them we do sell to the US
government there are a number of
applications that the government has
that call for the use of a floppy disk
the old saw is if it ain't broke don't
fix it most of our business is for
commercial and industrial use whether
they be embroidery machines ATMs
avionics for airplanes so those machines
are still around and they're going to
last for quite a few more years the
floppy disk business will not be around
forever no I won't be around forever
either
you